deal or no deal goes on the air is it
such an instant hit that now all of a
sudden you're not playing those little
shitty teepees anymore yeah i mean yes i
went to double shows overnight and it
was huge and so now you keep up the
schedule of doing hundreds of stand-up
shows a year i still do it why because
you want the money or you love it or
what that's my connection to people i'm
not social i don't really i'm not
comfortable around people but you're
comfortable on stage and i like to be i
want to be accepted so i you know i like
that i'm on stage and they they all came
to see me but do you and i hear that
laughter but do you like being on stage
i love being on stage it's the only
place i'm really comfortable it's the
only place in life that i feel
totally comfortable if you get that kind
of comfort level at what point in your
life do you get that because when you're
young stand up starting out i guess what
you started doing this in high school
well i was 23. 23 you started doing it
yeah okay at first yeah
aren't you nervous neurotic mess when
you first started i was so neurotic and
that's what my ass were funny
you know without knowing why i was funny
because i i was so [ __ ] scared and i
was contorting and uh you know i didn't
have an act and and people would kind of
giggle at my nervousness and i'd go what
what what what are you giggling and that
was my that was my thing you know and i
don't know if people remember it and
then i had all this [ __ ] i was holding
you know but that was just fear and
adrenaline and i'd have gloves on me
because i didn't want to touch things
and out of nothing to do i pulled a
rubber glove and i
pulled it on my head and blow it up and
they laughed at that and i went that's
funny okay that'll be my closing you
know
so so you never fantasized about being a
stand-up comic
why at 23 suddenly do you get this idea
when i was 23 years old in the middle in
the mid 70s there was this here too in
new york there was this comedy boom
right and these clubs started like here
you had catch a rising star and right
and in in toronto we had yuck yucks it's
the same club norm came out of right and
it was getting splashed all over the
paper and on a saturday night me and
three friends said let's go see a comedy
show i've never seen a stand-up comedy
show live right and we saw it and it
blew me away and there was there were
people my age on stage performing and
and it was it was i'd never saw anything
like this and mark breslin who owns it
he was the he got up he was the emcee
and he said you know on monday nights at
midnight
amateurs if you think you can do this
why don't you come up and show your
wares and the three guys at the table
with me said why don't you try it monday
night i said okay
it was like a knee-jerk reaction no
thought of ever getting into the
business
did you prepare for that night no well
here's the thing so i never even thought
of what it would be right so that night
i went home and i thought what the [ __ ]
did i just say yes to this would be fun
but then i thought i'll make some
jokes about i you know maybe a joke i
heard david brenner tell on the tonight
show maybe
no aspirations to make this a career
right you know i'll talk about uh
something my mom said to me i'll talk
about something my friend said so you
had a bit of an agenda a bit a bit and a
bit is like very little like nothing
nothing and then i so i go to the club
and uh we get there we watch a show and
then comes midnight and now i'm like
terrified and i go backstage and i heard
him go ladies and gentlemen a new young
comic he's from the carpet business
ladies and gentlemen howie mandel
what credits did i have i had a number's
carpet store yeah you may have bought
carpet from him and the light hits me
and i see people just sitting there
looking at me right and it was like [ __ ]
what the hell is it and i started like
it just
and and i saw my friends sitting there
and i started just laughing and going
look at this look at this and they
started laughing back at me people were
laughing and i go what what what no tell
me what
what are you laughing at and they go and
then they were laughing more and i go
what what oh this is me okay okay okay
okay okay okay let's and that was my ad
yeah i had nothing how long did you do
that where you just left it was a three
minute set i probably had one line that
i don't remember but you were a hit
because this idea of laughing but that
was spontaneous now the next time you go
on you can't go on and just start
laughing again and going well i wasn't
used to it he said come back next week
mark said come back i'm a hit
with what